كانت الديكة تعيش في الصين مع
ابنتهما هيرميون البالغة من العمر ثماني سنوات
عندما تفشى فيروس كورونا الجديد ،
كان أبي جيمس يعمل على بعد 200 ميل في
الوقت الذي تمكنت فيه أمي
بريسيلا وابنتهما البالغة من العمر ثماني سنوات
من الصعود إلى أحد هؤلاء الذين تم
إجلاؤهم.  الرحلات الجوية من ووهان
وهربوا كانوا آمنين حتى
أصيبت ابنتهم بالفيروس هنا
في الولايات المتحدة في ممفيس تينيسي ،
أود أن أشكركم على وجودكم
معي ، شكرًا جزيلاً على إصابة ابنتك
هيرميون بفيروس كورونا
الأسبوع الماضي وجيمس.  أعلم أنك كانت نتيجة اختبارك
إيجابية مع والديك ،
أخبرنا أولاً كيف يعمل الجميع بشكل
جيد ، نحن معلقون هناك
لحسن الحظ ، كانت
معظم أعراضنا خفيفة حتى
الآن ونحن فقط نبقى في
الحجر الصحي  البقاء في المنزل ومحاولة
كتابته الآن
و priscilla كما تعلم عندما
كنت تغادر أتخيل أن هناك
ارتياحًا كبيرًا للخروج من ووهان ، هل فكرت يومًا
أن الخطر الحقيقي عليك
كانت العائلة ستكون هنا في الولايات المتحدة ،
ولم أفكر أبدًا أننا كنا نخرج
أممم ونعم عندما ضرب كل شيء ، كنت مثل
أوه يا
إلهي ، نعم ، لم يكن شيئًا
يتبادر إلى الذهن أبدًا عندما كنا على تلك الطائرة
هل شعرت عندما غادرت تلك الطائرة
بأنك تركت التهديد وراءك وشعرت
بالارتياح ،
نعم
، تراكمت على المغادرة ،
كما تعلمون ، لقد فكرت في
أننا قادرون على الخروج ،
هل يمكننا ذلك؟  يمكن أن يكون آمنًا ،
نعم بالطبع ، هذا ما
اعتقده الجميع في تلك الطائرات
وأنتما في هذا
الوضع الفريد لأنك رأيت كيف
تعاملت الصين مع فيروس كورونا والآن
ترى كيف نفعل
جيمس يقارن ما رأيته هناك
ما تراه في الولايات المتحدة
جيدًا ، إنه حقًا الليل والنهار
لنكون صادقين
عندما كنا في الصين ، لم يكن بإمكانك
الخروج كثيرًا
وكان عليك دائمًا ارتداء
قناع لفحص درجة حرارتك
وأنت تعرف ذلك فقط  وصلت إلى
نقطة في بعض الأماكن في هوبى حيث
الناس  كانوا حتى
محاصرين داخل شقتهم
داخل شققهم
أه لم يكن الناس بالخارج وهنا أه
الجميع يخرجون فقط
يفعلون ما يريدون فعله
ولا يبدو أن هناك قلقًا كبيرًا بشأن
ما إذا كان الناس
سيرسلون  هذا المرض أم لا
، نعم ، وفي مكان ما بين
الإجراءات الصارمة التي رأيتها هناك في
الصين والسماح تمامًا لهذا الشيء
بالتحليق ،
هذه المناقشة حول ما يتم
في المنتصف ، لذا
أتساءل عنك بريسيلا وأنت تشاهد
ما يفعله الأمريكيون
ماذا تفعل  فكر في مدى جدية
تعاملهم مع الفيروس مع الأخذ في الاعتبار
ما تعرفه
كأم جيدًا ؛ يجب أن أقول إنهم لا
يأخذون الأمر على محمل الجد
بما فيه الكفاية ، فأنا أعيش الآن
هو مدينة صغيرة وليس
لديهم كل شيء  الكثير من الحالات
ليس هناك الكثير من
الخوف من ذلك ولكن في نفس الوقت علينا
أن نكون
أكثر حذرًا قليلاً بشأن كيفية
قيامنا بما نقوم به